[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
MICHAEL SIPSER: Why
don't we get started.
So as I like to do,
let's just review
where we have been
recently, which
is to discuss
context-free languages.
We talked about the context-free
grammars and the pushdown
automata as a way of describing
the context-free languages.
As you remember, the
context-free languages
are a larger class of languages
than the regular languages,
which is where we
started, the languages
of the finite automata.
So when you add a stack,
you get more power.
You get more languages
that you can do.
And we're very rapidly
going to be moving on today
to our main model for
the semester, which
is called the Turing machine.
So let's just take
a look at what we're
going to be covering today.
And that is, first,
we're going to show
that a technique analogous
to the one we use for proving
that languages are not regular,
but this time for proving
languages are not context-free.
So the pushdown
automata and the grammar
still have their limitations
in terms of what we normally
think a computer can do.
And with that, we're going to
use that as a kind of a lead-in
to our general-purpose model,
which is the Turing machine.
And so we're going
to talk about Turing
machines and aspects of that.
I would want to comment--
so I have posted the solutions
for the first problem set.
I know you're starting to think
about the second problem set
now, which I have
posted as well.
If you want to get a sense of
what I'm looking for in terms
of the level of detail, you
can look at the solutions
to problem set one,
because I consider
those to be model solutions.
That's part of the reason
why I post them, just
to give you a sense of the level
of detail that I'm looking for,
which is not a whole lot.
But I do want to
make sure you're
capturing the main
ideas of what's involved
in solving the problem.
So have a look at those.
And for problem set two, which
I'll talk about in a second--
so I'll just say a few words.
If you want to pull that
up, you can do that.
But just to get you started
on a few of the problems
if you're finding some
challenges there--
I don't want you
to get stuck really
before you even understand
what the problem is saying.
So for problem number one,
if you looked at that,
so that's a problem
where you're asked
to prove a certain language
is not context free.
And by the way, all of the
problems in this problem set
except perhaps for the
last, for number six,
you'll be able to solve.
We'll have enough material
at the end of today's lecture
to solve all of them.
I believe that's right.
Yeah, so number
six, you should have
enough as of Thursday's
lecture to solve that.
So problem number one,
it's proving a language
is not context free.
So we're going to introduce
a method for doing that.
That method is going
to come in handy.
For parts B and C, if you
look at the problem set,
it has this strange-looking
thing, sigma sigma
sigma in parenthesis star.
It's really just a regular
expression that's very simple.
You should just make
sure you understand
that that's a way of
representing all strings whose
length is a multiple of 3.
And if I stick a sigma
in front of that,
it's all strings whose length
is 1 plus a multiple of 3.
So once you understand
that, and if you
think about what kinds of
strings are in the language C2,
it'll help you to
understand what happens
when you take those unions.
And parts B and C are not
intended to be very hard,
but you just have to
understand what's going on.
Problem number two is
about ambiguous grammars.
I touched on that
briefly in lecture.
It's enough to
solve the problem.
The book has a little
bit more detail
about ambiguous languages,
ambiguous grammars--
ambiguous grammars,
I should say.
And so this is a
grammar that's supposed
to represent a fragment
of a programming language
with if thens and if then elses.
I'm sure you're all familiar
with those kinds of constructs
in programming languages.
And there is a natural
ambiguity that comes up
in a programming language.
If you have if some
condition then statement one,
else statement
two, I presume you
understand what the semantics
of that is, what that means.
And the tricky thing
is that if you have--
those statements can
themselves be if statements.
And so if you have the
situation where you have if then
and if then else is what
follows that, the question is,
where does the else attach?
Is it to the second
if or to the first if?
So that's kind of a big hint
on this problem, but that's OK.
You need to take
that and figure out
how to get an actual member
of the language which
is ambiguously generated,
and then show that it has--
show that it is by showing
two parse trees or two
leftmost derivations.
If you read the book, you'll
see that's an alternative way
of representing a parse tree.
So and then what
you're supposed to do
is give a grammar for the same
language which is unambiguous.
You don't have to prove
that it's unambiguous,
because that's a bit of a chore.
But as long as you
understand what's going on,
you should be able to come up
with an unambiguous grammar
which resolves that ambiguity.
And I don't have in mind
changing the language
by introducing new
programming language
constructs like a "begin end."
That's not in the
spirit of this problem,
because that's a
different-- it's grammar
for a different language.
So you need to be
generating the same language
without any other extraneous
things going on that are
going to resolve the ambiguity.
The ambiguity needs to be
resolved within the structure
of the grammar itself.
So keep that in mind.
For problem number three
about the queue automata,
you know, that came up actually
as a suggestion last lecture,
I believe, or two lectures back.
What happens if you take a
pushdown automaton, but instead
of a pushdown--
instead of a stack,
you add a queue.
What happens then?
Well actually, it turns
out that the model you get
is very powerful.
And it turns out to
be equivalent in power
to a Turing machine.
So you'll see
arguments of that kind
today, how you show that other
models are equivalent-- no, not
today.
So I apologize.
This is going to be
something that you'll--
I'm confusing myself here.
Problem number three actually
needs Thursday's lecture
as well to really at
least see examples of how
you do that kind of thing.
Yeah, so I'll try to send
out a note clarifying this.
By the end of Thursday, you'll
be able to do everything,
except for problem six.
And for problem six, you'll
need Tuesday's lecture, a week
from today's lecture, to do.
So problem number
four, that one you'll
be able to do at
the end of today.
That's also going
to-- the problem
is I'm working on preparing
Thursday's lecture too.
So I'm getting a little--
I'm confusing myself.
Problem number four,
you'll be able to do
after Thursday's lecture.
Maybe we should talk
about that next lecture.
Problem number five,
you can do today,
but maybe I'm not going to
say anything about that.
And problem number six, I won't
say anything about either.
OK, so why don't we
just jump in then
and look at today's material.
What about seven?
Oh, seven is an
optional problem.
Oh, I should have
mentioned that.
Seven is always going
to be an option.
I indicate that
with a star I should
have made that clear on the
actual description here,
but seven is optional.
It's just like we had
for problem set one.
OK, let's move
let's move on, then,
to what we're going
to talk about today.
And just a little
bit of review--
so we talked about
the equivalence
of context-free grammars
and pushdown automata,
as you remember.
Oops, let me get myself
out of the picture here.
As we mentioned last
time, we actually proved
one direction, but the
other direction of that,
you just have to know
it's true, but you
don't have to know the proof.
The proof is a little
bit lengthy, I would say.
It's a nice proof,
but it's pretty long.
And there are two important
corollaries to that.
If you know what a
corollary is, it's
just a simple
consequence which doesn't
need much of a
proof, sort of a very
straightforward consequence.
First of all, I think we
pointed out last time,
one conclusion, one
corollary you get
is that every regular language
is a context-free language,
because a finite automaton is
a pushdown automaton that just
happens not to use its stack.
So immediately, you get that
every language is context free.
And second of all, you
also immediately get
that whenever you have
a context-free language
and a regular language and
you take their intersection,
you get back a
context-free language.
So context free intersect
regular is context free.
That's actually mentioned in
your homework as well as one
of the 0.x problems which
I give to try to get you--
you don't have to turn those in,
but I suggest you look at them.
I don't know how many of
you are looking at them.
But this is a useful fact.
And some of those other facts
in 0.x problems are useful.
So I encourage you
to look at them.
But anyway, intersection
of context free and regular
is context free.
You might ask, what about
intersection of context
free and context free?
Do we have closure
under intersection?
The answer is, no,
we do not have close
to closure under intersection.
We'll talk about that shortly.
So here is the
proof sketch for--
I wanted to say that the
intersection of context
free and regular, why do we
know that's still context free?
Because the pushdown
automaton for A
can be simulating
the finite automaton
for B inside its finite control,
inside its finite memory.
The problem is, if you have
two context-free languages,
you have two pushdown
automata, you
can't simulate that with
one pushdown automaton,
because it has only
a single stack.
So if you're trying to take
the intersection of two
context-free languages
with only a single stack,
you're going to be in trouble,
because it's hard to--
anyway, that's not a
proof, but at least it
shows you what goes wrong if
you try to do the obvious thing.
OK, so if-- and just,
here is an important point
that was trying to make before.
If A and B are both
context free and you're
taking the intersection, the
result may not necessarily
be a context-free language.
So the class of
context-free languages
is not closed under
its intersection.
We'll comment on that in a bit.
The context-free languages
are closed under the regular
operations, however,
union, intersection--
union, concatenation, and star.
So you should feel
comfortable that you
know how to prove that.
Again, it's one of the--
I think it's problem 0.2.
And I think the solution is
even given in the book for it.
So you just should
know how to prove that.
It's pretty straightforward.
OK, so let's move on then
to basically conclude
our work on
context-free languages,
to understand the limitations
of context-free grammars,
and what kinds of languages
may not be context free.
And how do you prove that?
So how do you prove
that, for some language,
there is no grammar?
Again, you know,
it's not enough just
to, say, give an informal
comment that, I couldn't
think of a grammar, or some--
things of that kind.
That's not going
to be good enough.
We need to have a proof.
So if we take the language
here, 0 to the k, 1 to the k,
2 to the k, so those
are strings which
are runs of 0's followed
by an equal number of 1's
followed by an equal
number of 2's, so just 0's,
then 1's, then 2's,
all the same length.
That's a language
which is not going
to be a context-free language.
And we'll give a method
for proving that.
If you had a stack, you can
match the 1's with the 0's, but
then once you're done with
that, the stack is empty.
And how do you now make
sure that the number of 2's
corresponds to the number
of 1's that you had?
So again, that's an
informal argument
that's not good
enough to be a proof,
but it sort of
gives an intuition.
So we're going to give a method
for proving non-context-free--
languages are not context free
using, again, a pumping lemma.
But this is going to
be a pumping lemma that
applies to
context-free language,
not to regular languages.
It looks very similar, but
it has some extra wrinkles
thrown in, because the other
older pumping lemma was
specific to the
regular languages.
And this is going to be
something that applies
to the context-free languages.
OK, so now let's just read it.
And then we'll try to
interpret it again.
It's very similar in spirit.
Basically, it says
that, whenever
you have a
context-free language,
all long strings
in the language can
be pumped in some kind of way.
So it's going to be a
little different kind
of pumping than we had before.
And you stay in the language.
OK, so before, we broke the
string into three pieces
where we could repeat that
centerpiece as many times
as you like.
And you stay in the language.
Here, we're going
to end up breaking
the string into five pieces.
So s is going to be
broken up into uvxyz.
And the way it's going to work
here-- so here is a picture.
So all long strings--
again, there
is going to be a threshold.
So whenever you have
a language, there
is going to be some
cut-off length.
So all the longer strings in
that language can be pumped.
And you stay in the language.
But the shorter strings,
there is no guarantee.
So if you have a long string in
the language of length at least
this pumping length p,
then you can break it up
into five pieces.
But now it's that second
and fourth string that
are going to play that special
pumping role, which means that,
what you can do is
you can repeat those
and you stay in the language.
And it's important
that you repeat
them both, that v and that
y, the same number of times.
So you're going to
have a picture that
looks something like this.
And that is going to you repeat.
If you repeat the v and you
repeat the y, you get uvvxyyz.
Or if you look at
over here, it would
be uv squared xy squared z.
And that's going to
still be in the language.
And then we have--
so that's one condition.
We'll have to look at
all of these conditions
when we do the
proof, but we just
want to understand what
the statement is right now.
So the second condition is
that v and y together cannot be
empty.
And really, that's another
way of saying, they can't both
be the empty string,
because if they
were both the empty
string, then repeating
them wouldn't change s.
And then of course it
would stay in the language.
So it would be
kind of meaningless
if they were
allowed to be empty.
And the last thing
is, again, going
to be there as a
matter of convenience
for proving languages are not
context free, because you have
to make sure there is no
possible way of cutting up
the string.
When you're trying to prove a
language is not context free,
you have to show
the pumping fails.
It's going to be
helpful sometimes
to limit the ways in which
the string can be cut up,
because then you have--
it's an easier job for
you to work with it.
So here, it's a little
different than before,
but sort of similar, that
vxy combine as a substring.
So I show that over here.
vxy together is not too long.
So the vxy-- maybe it's
better seen up here--
is going to be, at most, p.
We'll do an example in
a minute of using this.
OK, so again, here
is our pumping lemma.
I've just restated it.
So we have it in front of us.
And we're going to do a proof.
I'm just going to give you
the idea of the proof first.
And then we'll go through
some of the details.
The idea is actually
pretty simple.
We give it-- call it
a proof by picture.
Again, remember what
we're trying to do.
We're trying to show that we
have this context-free language
A. And now all long strings in
A have this pumping quality,
that you can break them
up into five pieces so
that the second and the
fourth piece can be repeated.
And you stay in the language.
So how do we know that
that's going to be true?
Let's take a look
at the proof here.
And why is that
going to be true?
So first of all, I'd like to
do it qualitatively rather
than quantitatively.
So let's just imagine,
instead of thinking-- we'll
calculate what p is later.
But just imagine that s is some
really, really long string.
That's the way I like
to think about it.
So s is just really long.
What is that going to tell us?
It's going to tell us something
important about the way
the grammar produces s, which
is going to be useful in getting
a way of pumping it.
So if s is really
long, we're going
to look at the parse tree for s.
And we're going to conclude
that the parse tree has
to be really tall, because
it's impossible for a very
shallow parse tree to
generate a very long string.
And again, we'll quantify
that in a second.
But intuitively,
I think that's not
too hard to see why
that ought to be true.
So if you have a long
s, the parse tree
has to be really tall,
because the parse tree can't
generate very many--
it can't expand
by very much at each level.
So we'll look at how
much it can expand.
But it depends on the
grammar, how much expansion
have at each level.
And it's going to be-- you
can't have just in three levels
some small grammar generating
a string of length 1 million.
You'll see that that's
just impossible.
So once you know that the
parse tree is really tall here,
then you're actually
almost done, because what
does it mean to be really tall?
It means that there is some path
starting at the start variable
E, I'm calling it in this
parse tree, which goes down
to some terminal symbol in s,
which goes through many steps.
That's what it means for
the tree to be very tall.
And each one of those
steps is a variable
until you get down
to the very end.
OK, so that's the
way parse trees look.
You keep expanding variables
until you get to a terminal.
So here, you get some path
that's really a long path.
And once you have
a long path that
has many, many variables
appearing on here,
well, the grammar itself
has only some fixed number
of variables in
it, so you're going
to have to have a repetition
coming among the variables that
occur on that long path.
Got that?
So a long string forces
a tall parse tree,
forces a repetition on
some path coming out
of the start variable of some
other variable that comes out.
Now that's going to
tell us how to cut up s,
because if you look
at the subtrees of s
that those two R variables are
generating, shown like this,
I'm going to use that--
so you have to follow
what I'm saying here.
So R here is generating
this portion of s.
And the lower R is generating
a smaller portion of s,
just looking at the
subtree that you get here.
And that's going to tell us that
we can cut up s accordingly.
So u was that very first
part out here generated
by E, but not by the
first R. R is generated--
v is generated by the first
R, but not by the second R.
The second R
generates exactly x.
And then we have y
and z, similarly.
So that all follows from
having a tall parse tree.
And now we're finished.
Now we know how to cut up s.
How do we know we
can repeat v and y
and still be in the language?
Well, I'll actually show you
that you're in the language
by exhibiting a parse tree
for the string uvvxyyz.
Here it is.
I'm going to get that parse tree
by, when I expand this lower R,
instead of expanding
it to get x,
I'm going to follow the same
substitutions that I had when
I expanded the upper R. So
it's as if I took this larger
subtree here and I substituted
it in for the smaller subtree
under the second R. And so I get
a picture that looks like this.
So here I'm substituting under
the second R the same subtree
that I had originally coming
out of the upper R, the first R.
And so now this parse tree is
generating the string uvvxyyz,
which is what I'm looking for.
And of course, you can
do that again and again.
And you're going to keep getting
higher and higher exponents
of v and y.
And in fact, you can
even get the 0 exponent,
which means that v and y
both disappear altogether.
And for that, you do
something slightly different,
which is that you replace the
larger subtree by the smaller
subtree.
OK so here, which was originally
that larger tree generating
vxy, I stick instead
the smaller subtree.
I do the substitutions
from the smaller subtree.
And I just get x there.
And so now the
string I generated
is uxz, which is the same as
uv to the 0 xy to the 0 z.
And that is the
idea of the proof.
Now, I think you could work out
the quantities that you need
in order to drive this proof.
I'm going to do that for you.
I actually hate writing
down lots of inequalities,
and equations, and
so on, on the board,
because I think
they're just almost
incomprehensible to follow.
Or at least they
would be for me.
But I'm going to put
them up there just
for completeness sake.
So here we're going to give
the details of this proof
on the next slide here.
Oh yeah, so I just want
to give a name to this.
I'm going to call this the
cutting and pasting argument,
because I'm cutting apart
pieces of this parse tree
and I'm pasting them in to other
places within the parse tree
to get new strings
being generated.
So this is a cutting
and pasting argument.
So OK, let's take a look
at the details here, just,
well, we have to
understand, well,
how big does p actually need
to be in order for this thing
to kick in?
Well, first of all,
we have to understand
how fast that parse
tree can be growing
as we go level to level.
And that's going to be dependent
on how big the right-hand sides
of rules are.
I mean, that really
tells you how many--
what's the fan out
you know of each node?
What's the maximum fan out?
And that's going to
be the maximum length
of a right-hand
side of any rule.
So for example, in
that other grammar
we had seen last time for
arithmetic expressions,
we had this E goes to E
plus T, this rule here.
And in terms of the
parse tree, that
would look like a little
element like that.
And that's actually the
longest right-hand side
that you can get.
And so the parse tree can
be growing by a factor of 3
each time.
Now, that's going to tell
us how big the string needs
to be that's being generated,
what is the value of p
in order to get a high enough
parse tree so that you're going
to get a repeated variable.
Let's call the height of
the parse tree for S h.
So now if you-- this is just
repeating what I just said.
If you have a tree of height
h and the maximum branching
is b, then you get, at
most, b to the h leaves,
because each level, you get
another factor of b coming up,
because that's how much
branching you have.
So each node at one
level can become b nodes
at the next level down.
So you're multiplying
by b each time.
And if you have h
levels, you're going
to have b to the h leaves.
So the length of s, which
are really the leaves here,
is at most b to the h.
The reason why it's at
most and not exactly
is you might be doing
some substitutions which
are shorter right-hand sides.
OK, so to try to show
this as a picture
here, pulling that same
picture we had before,
we want h, the
height, to be bigger
than the number of variables
to force a repetition.
So the number of variables is
going to be written this way.
V is the variables.
V with bars around it is going
to be the number of variables.
And we want that
height to be greater
than the number of variables.
So once you know how high you
want that tree to be in order
to force a repetition, then it
tells you how big s has to be.
So V has to be bigger than b
to the V, b to the size of V,
because then the height
that you're going to get
is going to be greater
than the size of V, which
is-- so that's what you want.
You want h to be greater
than the size of V.
So you're going to set p to
be one more than b to the V.
And so if s is at
least that length,
this whole thing is
going to kick in.
And you're going to get
that repeated variable.
So we'll let p to
be that value where
V is the number of
variables in the grammar.
And so if s is at least p, which
is greater than b to the V,
then the length of s is going
to be greater than b to the V.
So h is going to be what you
want to make this thing work.
If you don't follow
that, those inequalities,
I sympathize with you.
I would never follow
that either in a lecture.
So but I hope you get the idea.
But we're not
quite finished yet,
because I want to now circle
back, and look at these three
conditions, and make sure
that we've captured them all,
because actually, it's not
totally obvious in each
of those cases that
we've got them.
So there is a few extra
things we need to do.
OK, so this is
concluding the argument.
There are going to be at least V
plus 1 variables in the longest
path.
So there is going
to be a repetition.
So now let's go back
here and see, now
that we have this picture
with a repeated variable,
how do we know we can
get condition one?
Well, that's just the
cutting and pasting argument
from the previous slide.
How do we know that v
and y are not both empty?
Well actually, that's
not totally obvious,
because it's possible that,
when you generated v here
and you generated y, maybe
going from this R to that R,
you got nothing new.
You know, it could have been
that R got replaced by T,
another variable with
nothing new coming out,
and then T got replaced by R.
You substituted T for
R and then R for T.
And you've got nothing
new coming out.
And in that case, v and y
would both be the empty string.
And that would
violate what we want.
The way you get around-- that
and these are details here.
If you're not totally following
these points, don't worry.
They're easy to describe.
So I figure, let me present
the whole thing in full detail.
So if going from this R to that
R doesn't generate anything
new, you're getting exactly
the same things coming out--
v and y are just
the empty string--
how do we avoid
that from happening?
There is a simple way to
address that, which is to say,
if you have this string s,
when you take a parse tree,
make sure you take a
small-as-possible parse tree.
You're not allowed to start off
with an inefficient parse tree
that can be shortened
and still generate s.
I want the smallest
possible parse tree.
And that smallest
possible parse tree
can't have an R going
to another R which
is generating nothing new,
because then you could always
have eliminated that step.
And you would still
have a parse tree for s,
but it would be a
smaller parse tree.
So that would be--
I want you to start off with the
smallest possible parse tree.
And then you're going to be
guaranteed that v or y is going
to be something not empty.
So that takes care
of condition two.
Condition three-- you know, how
do we know that vxy together
is not very long?
And basically, it's the same
argument all over again.
You just want to make
sure that, when you're
picking the repetition
R, the two R's here,
you pick the lowest possible
repetitions that occur,
if you have many choices.
And those lowest two,
those lowest repetitions,
there is not going to be
any lower repetition here.
And then by the same
argument, since once you
have that very first R, there
is no more repetitions occurring
below, the vxy
can't be very long,
because that would, again, force
another repetition to occur.
So anyway, those are
the three conditions.
And that's the proof
of the pumping lemma
for h free languages.
Let's see how we use that.
OK, so let's do an example
of proving a language
not context free using
the pumping lemma.
How are you going to
go about doing that?
Because that's the kind of
thing, at the very least,
you need to know how to do this
in order to do the homework.
I'd like to motivate
you that the stuff is
so interesting and fun, but
it doesn't work for everybody.
So for you practical people
out there, pay attention
so you can do the homework.
OK, let's go back
to that language
we had a couple of slides
back, 0 to the k, 1 to the k,
2 to the k.
It's not a
context-free language.
We're going to show that
now using the pumping lemma
for context-free languages.
So it's going to do,
similar to the proofs using
for non-regular languages,
proof by contradiction.
So you, first you assume the
language is context-free.
And then we're going to
apply the pumping lemma.
And then we're going
to get a contradiction.
So the pumping lemma
gives that pumping length,
as we described above.
And now we just want to pick a
longer string in the language
and show that that
longer string, which
is supposed to be pumpable and
stay in the language, in fact
is not pumpable.
So the pumping
lemma says that you
can divide it into five
pieces satisfying the three
conditions.
Condition three implies that--
so now I'm going to I'm
going to work through.
I'm going to show you
get a contradiction.
So condition three implies
that you cannot contain both
0's and--
let's pull up a picture here.
So here is s, 0's, 1's, and then
2's, all of the same length.
Condition three-- so
if you break it up,
condition three says, vxy
together cannot be too long.
Well, if vxy together
is not too long,
how could it be that, when
you're repeating v and y,
you stay in the language?
For one thing, you can't
have 0's, 1's, and 2's all
occurring within v, x, and y.
Some symbol is going
to get left out.
So then when you
pump up, you're going
to have unequal
numbers of symbols.
And so you're going to
be out of the language.
OK, so no matter how
you try to cut it up
following condition three,
which is one of the things that
restricts the ways
to cut it up, you're
going to end up, when you pump
up, going out of the language.
And so therefore, it's not in--
D?
D is wrong.
B, should say "B."
I'm supposed to be able
to write on this thing.
I guess not.
I didn't test that.
Oh well, that's
supposed to be a B.
So B is a context-free
language, which includes--
so that's the assumption, that
B is a context-free language.
That's false.
And we conclude that it's
not a context-free language.
Let's do-- oh yeah, I
have a check in here.
So let's see what I'm going
to ask you to think about.
OK, my head is blocking
part of the text?
Oh, that was a while ago.
Yes, so just one
question by the way,
in terms of applying the
pumping lemma-- either v or y
can be empty, but not both.
But anyway, let's get
to this check in here.
So let's look at these
two languages, A1 and A2,
which look very similar to
B, but a little different.
So it's A1 is 0 to
the k, 1 to the k, 2
to the l, where k and
l could be any numbers,
any positive,
non-negative numbers.
So basically what
this is saying is
that the number of 0's and
1's are going to be equal,
but the number of 2's can be
anything, whereas A2, similar,
but here, we're
requiring the number
of 1's and 2's to be equal.
And the number of
0's can be anything.
Now, you can easily
make, I hope--
you should make sure you can--
pushdown automata that
can recognize A1 and A2,
because let's just take A1.
The pushdown automaton can push
the 0's as it's reading them,
pop them as it's reading
the 1's to match them off
and make sure that they're
the same number of them.
And then the 2's, it doesn't
care how many there are.
It just has to make sure
that there are no strings,
there are no letters
coming out of order.
But any number of 2's is fine.
So you can easily make a
pushdown automaton recognizing
A1, similarly for A2.
So what can we
conclude from that?
Here are the three
possibilities.
Let me-- so look at that, the
class of context-free languages
is not closed
under intersection.
You can read it.
So I want to pull up the
poll and launch that.
Please fill that out.
10 seconds.
Again, just, if you
don't know the answer,
just give any answers so that--
because we're not
counting correctness.
There is still a
few dribbling in.
OK, five seconds.
OK, end polling.
Most of you got that right.
I don't know.
Is it OK to share these things?
I don't want to make people who
didn't get the right feel bad.
You know, but you
should understand,
I think if you're
missing something,
you should understand
what you're missing.
The pumping lemma shows
that A1 union A2 is not
a context-free language?
No.
As I mentioned at the beginning,
the context-free languages
are closed under union.
So the pumping lemma had
better not show that these--
we already know that
these two languages
are context free, because we get
them from pushdown automaton.
And we said at the beginning
that context-free language
is closed under union.
So we know that these
two are context free.
So the pumping lemma
better not show
that they're not context free.
Something would be terribly--
have gone terribly wrong
if that were true.
And also we know also from a
little bit of further reasoning
that the context-free
languages is not
closed under complement by
what we've already discussed,
because they are
closed under union.
And as I pointed out, they're
not closed under intersection.
And so if they were
closed under complement,
De Morgan's Laws
would say that closure
under union and closure
under complement
would give you closure
under intersection.
But we don't have closure
So in fact, they're not
closed under complement.
OK, so in fact,
this does show us
that the class of
context-free language
is not closed
under intersection,
because the intersection
of A1 and A2,
two context-free languages, is
B. And B is not context free.
So it shows that this is--
the closure under
intersection does not hold.
So let us continue, then.
We have one more example.
Then we'll take a break.
So the pumping lemma for
context-free languages,
again, here is the
second example.
Here is the language F. We
have actually seen this before.
ww, two copies of a string,
two copies of any string--
and we're going to show that's
not a context-free language.
Assume that it is context
free, the pumping lemma
gives pumping length.
Now, here you have to do
a little bit more work.
Often, the challenge in
applying the pumping lemma
in either case that
we've seen involves
choosing that string
that you need to pump,
that you're going to pump.
So you have to choose
s in F, which is longer
than p, which s to go with.
So you might try this
one, first glance.
Here is a string
that's in the language,
because it's two copies of
the string 0 to the p1 0
to-- and then 0 to the p1.
So that's in the language,
but it's a bad choice.
Before I get ahead
of myself, let's
draw a picture of s, which I
think is always helpful to see.
So here is runs of 0's and then
a 1, runs of 0's and then a 1.
Why is this a bad choice?
Because you can pump that string
and you remain in the language.
There is a way to
cut that string up
and you'll stay in the language.
And the way to cut
it up is to let
the x be just that substring
which is just the 1.
And the v and y can be a
couple of 0's or a single 0
on either side of that 1.
And now that's going
to be a small vxy.
But if you repeat
v and y, you're
going to stay in the
language, because you'll just
be adding 0's here.
You'll be adding same
number of 0's there.
And then you're going
to have a string which
still looks like ww.
And you'll still
be in the language.
So that means that cutting
it up doesn't get you out
of the language under pumping.
And the fact is that
that's a bad choice for s,
because there is that
way of cutting it up.
So you have to show
there's no way--
you don't get to pick
the way to cut it up.
You have to show that there is
no way to cut it up in order
to violate the pumping lemma.
So if instead you use the
string 0 to the p, 1 to the p,
0 to the p, 1 to the p-- so this
is 0's followed by 1's followed
by 0's followed by 1's, all
the same number of them--
that can't be pumped satisfying
the three conditions.
And just going through that--
now if you try to break it
up, you're going to lose.
Or the lemma is going to lose.
You're going to be
happy, but the lemma
is not going to be happy,
because it's not going-- it's
going to violate the condition.
Condition three
says vxy is not--
doesn't span too
much, and in fact,
can't span two runs of
0's or two runs of 1's.
It's just not big
enough, because they're
more than p things--
they're p things apart.
And this one string, this
string vxy is only p long.
And so therefore, if
you repeat v and y,
you're going to have two
runs of 0's or two 1's
that have unequal length.
And now that's not
going to be the form ww.
You're going to be
out of the language.
So I hope that's--
you've got a little
practice with that.
I think we're at our break.
And I will see you back
here in five minutes,
if I can get my
timer launched here.
OK, so see you soon.
This is a good time, by the
way, to message me or the TAs.
And I'll try to be looking
for if you have any questions.
In the pumping lemma, can x--
yeah, x can be epsilon
in the pumping lemma.
x can be epsilon.
y can be epsilon, but x and
y cannot both be epsilon,
because then, when you pump,
you'll get nothing new.
Technically, v and y can
include both 0's and 1's.
Yeah, v and y can
So let me try to put that
back, if that's will--
so v and y can have both 0's
and 1's, but they can't have
0's from two different blocks.
And you can't have 1's
from two different blocks.
So what's going to
happen is either you're
going to get things out
of order when you repeat--
like, a v has both
0's and 1's in it.
When you repeat v,
you're going to have
0's and 1's, and 0's and
1's, and 0's and 1's.
That's clearly out of the
language, so that's no good.
Your only hope is to have v
to be sticking only inside
the 0's and y to be sticking
only inside 0's or only inside
1's.
But now, if you repeat
that and just look
at what you're
going to get, you're
going to have a string
which is going to be--
if you try to cut
that string in half,
it's not going to be
of the right form.
It's not going to be two
copies of the same string,
because it's going to have a
run of 0's followed by a longer
or shorter run of
0's, or a run of 1's
followed by another run
of 1's of unequal length.
So there is no way this
can be two strings, two
copies of the same
string, because that's
what you required.
F has to be two copies
of the same string
to be in the language.
OK, let me just see where--
we're running out of time here.
Let me just put my timer here.
We've only got 30 seconds.
And I'm sorry I'm not getting to
answer all the questions here.
OK, we are done with our break.
It's going to come back.
And now we're shifting
gears in a major way,
because in a sense,
everything we've
done so far has been
kind of a warm up.
These limited
computational models
really are kind of
helping us to set
our understanding of
automata and the definitions
and the notation.
And they're also going to be
helpful in providing examples
later on in the term.
But really, in terms of
a model of computation,
they don't cut it, because they
cannot do very simple things
that we normally think of a
computer as being able to do.
So here we're introducing
another model of computation,
called the Turing machine.
And that's really going to
be the model of what we're
going to stick with for
the rest of the semester,
because that's going
to be our model
of a general-purpose
computer, the way
you normally think about it.
So let's-- we'll spend a
little time introducing it.
And then we we'll continue
that discussion next time.
So in terms of a
schematic, actually,
the Turing machine
model is pretty simple.
It's going to have states
and all that stuff.
So there is going to be a
finite control here, which
is going to include states
and a transition function,
as we'll describe in a minute.
The point is that
it's going to have
the input appearing on a tape.
The key difference now
is that the machine
is going to be able to change
the symbols on the tape.
And so we think of the machine
as being able to write as well
as read the tape.
So that's really the key
feature of a Turing machine,
is the ability to
write on the tape.
Everything else, in a
sense, follows from that,
and a few other differences.
But so the fact that the
head can read and write
so that we can use
the tape as storage
much as we use the
stack of storage,
but it's not limited in the
way we can access it the way a
stack is--
so we kind of have
very flexible access
of the information on the tape.
Now, being able to
write on the tape
doesn't do any good if
you can't go back and read
what you've written later on.
So we're going to make the
head to be able to be two way.
So the head can move
left to right as before,
but it can also move back left.
And that's going to be under
control of the transition
function, so under program
control, essentially.
The tape is going to be--
oops, sorry.
The tape is infinite
to the right.
And so we're not going to limit
how much storage the machine
can have.
So the tape is going to-- we'll
think of as having, instead
of just having the input on it,
it's going to have the input.
But then the rest,
it's going to have
infinitely many blanks, blank
symbols following the input.
So the tape is infinite in
the right-hand direction.
And so there is
infinitely many blanks.
I'm going to use that symbol for
the blank to follow the input.
You can accept or reject.
Oh yeah, so that's another
thing that's important.
Normally, we think of--
in the previous machines, finite
automata, pushdown automata,
when you got to the
end of the input,
that's when the acceptance
or rejection was decided.
If you were going to accept
it at the end of the input,
then you accepted.
But you have to be
in that location
at the end of the input in
order for that to take effect.
That doesn't make
any sense anymore,
because the machine
might go off beyond that,
and still be computing, and come
back and read the tape later
on.
So it only really
makes sense to let
the machine accept or reject
upon entering the accept
or reject state.
So we're going to have
a special accept state
and a special reject
state, which is also
a little different than before.
And when the machine
enters those states,
then the machine--
then the action takes effect.
The machine halts and then
accepts or halts and then
rejects.
So we'll make that absolutely
clear in the formal definition
in a second, but just
to get the spirit of it.
So I'm going to give you an
example of the thing running.
Sorry, me too-- again, my
PowerPoint is having issues.
OK, so here is a Turing machine
recognizing that language b.
Actually, I switched
gears on you.
Instead of 0's, 1's, and 2's,
I made them a's, b's, and c's,
but the same idea.
So I'm going to show you how
the Turing machine operates.
And then we'll give
a formal definition.
I hope that's on here.
I think it is.
In a second, but let's--
this is an informal discussion
of how the machine is going
to operate to do this language,
a to the k, b to the k, c
to the k, using its ability
to write on the tape
as well as read and move
its head in both directions.
OK, so let me just first
describe in English
how this machine operates.
And then we will
see it in action
on this little picture
I have over here.
So the way the machine
is going to operate
is the very first thing is the
head is going to start here.
And the head is going to
scan off to the right,
making sure that the symbols
appear in the correct order.
So it's seeing that there
are a's and b's and then c's,
without checking the quantities,
just that the order is correct.
For that, you don't
need to write.
A finite automaton can check
that the input is of the form
a star, b star, c star.
So writing is not necessary.
The machine, if it detects
symbols out of order,
it immediately rejects by going
into a special reject state.
Otherwise, it's going to return
its head back to the left end.
And let me just show that here.
So here is-- oh no.
Before I illustrate
it over here,
let's go through
the whole algorithm.
So the next thing that happens
is you're going to scan right.
And now you want
to do the counting.
So you're going to
scan right again,
but this time,
you're going to make
a bunch of passes over the
input, a bunch of scans.
And each time you
make a scan, you're
going to cross off one
symbol of each type.
So you're going
to cross off an a.
You'll cross off a b.
You'll cross off a
c on a single scan.
And then you repeat that,
crossing off the next a,
the next b, the next c.
And you want to make
sure that you've
crossed off all of the
symbols on the same run
and not crossing off some
symbols before other symbols,
while other symbols will
remain, because that would mean
that the counts were not equal.
If you cross them
off and they're all
run out on the same
scan, same pass,
then we know that the numbers
had to start off being equal.
So I mean, this is a
sort of baby stuff here,
but I hope you get the idea.
And we'll kind of
illustrate it in a second.
If you have the last
one of each symbol--
so what I mean by
that is you just
crossed off the last a, the
last b, and the last c--
then that you originally
had an equal number.
And so you accept, because
you're crossing off
one of each on each scan.
So if you cross off, on the
last scan, each one of them
gets crossed off,
then you accept.
But if it was the last of
some symbol but not of other
symbols, so you crossed off the
last a, but there were several
b's remaining, then you started
off with an unequal number
of a's, b's, and c's.
Then you can reject.
Or if all symbols still remain
after you have crossed them,
one on each off, then you
haven't done enough passes.
And you're going to
repeat from stage three
and do that again another scan.
OK, so here is a
little animation
which shows this
happening on this diagram.
So here is the very first stage
where you're scanning across,
making sure things are
in the right order.
I didn't have to
write on the tape.
And now you're going to reset
the head back to the beginning.
This is, by the way, not
the most efficient procedure
for doing this.
Now we're going to do
a scan crossing off
a single a, a single
b, and a single c.
So here, I'm going to show that
here, a single a, a single b,
single c.
And now as soon as you have
crossed out that last c,
we can return back
to the beginning.
So scan right across--
so if all symbols remain,
so there are still
symbols remaining
of each type, we're
going to return to
the left and repeat.
Now we're getting another
pass, single a, single b,
single c get crossed off.
Have we crossed
them all off yet?
No, there is-- of each type,
there still are remaining ones.
So again, we return
back to the beginning.
Now we have a last
pass, cross off
the last a, the
last b, the last c.
The last one of each
type was crossed off.
So now we know we can accept,
because the original string
was in the language.
OK, so that's to give you at
least some idea how the Turing
machine can operate,
more like the way
you would think of a
computer operating.
Maybe it's very primitive.
You could imagine counting also.
And a Turing machine
can count as well.
But this is the
simplest procedure
that I can just describe
for you without making
it too complicated.
OK, so let's do a
little checking on that.
OK, so the way I'm describing
this, how do you think?
And in a sense, you don't
quite know enough yet.
But how do you think we're going
to get this effect of crossing
off with the Turing machine?
Are we going to get that
by changing the model
and adding that ability
to cross off to the model?
Are we going to use
a tape alphabet that
includes those crossed-off
symbols among them?
Or we'll just assume
that all Turing
machines come with an
eraser and they can always
cross off stuff.
So what do you think is the nice
way, sort of mathematically,
to describe this ability
to cross things off?
Yeah, again, most of you,
again, I think are getting this.
So there are, like,
10 laggards here.
So please wrap it up so
we can close the poll.
Five seconds to go.
OK, polling ending, get
your last-- last call.
All right, share the results.
So most of you got that right.
All Turing machines
come with the eraser--
I don't know.
That was thrown in there as a
joke, but it came in second.
So don't feel bad if
you got it, but that's
not what I had in mind.
The way the Turing machine is
going to be writing on the tape
is to write a crossed-off
symbol instead of the symbol
that was originally there.
So we're going to add these
new crossed-off symbols.
And that's going to be a
common thing for us to do
when we design Turing machines.
We're not going to get down
to the implementation level
for very long.
We're going to
very quickly shift
to a higher level of
discussion about the machines.
But anyway, that's
how you would do it
if you were going to
actually build a machine.
So let us then look at
the formal definition.
And personally, maybe I
should have done that check
in after the formal definition.
That might have been
clearer, but oh well.
OK, Turing-- here is
the formal definition.
This time, a Turing
machine is a 7-tuple.
And there is-- now
here, we have sigma,
which is the input alphabet.
Gamma is the tape alphabet.
So now you're a little
bit analogous to the stack
from before where gamma
was the stack alphabet.
But these are the
symbols that you're
allowed to write on the tape--
that are allowed
to be on the tape.
So obviously, all
of the input symbols
are among the tape
symbols, because they
can appear on the tape.
So you have sigma is
a subset of gamma.
One thing I didn't
mention here is
that the input alphabet, we
don't allow the blank symbol
to be in the input alphabet,
so that you can actually
use the blank symbol
as a delimiter
for the end of the
input, a marker
for the end of the input.
So in fact, and the
blank symbol is always
going to be in
the tape alphabet.
This is actually always going
to be a proper subset because
of the blank symbol.
But we're just allowing--
it doesn't really matter.
We're allowing the
tape alphabet to have
other symbols for
convenience, so for example,
these crossed-off symbols.
Now let's look at what
the transition function,
how that operates.
So the transition
function, remember,
tells how the machine is
actually doing its computation.
And it says that, if you're in
a certain state and the head
is looking at a
certain tape symbol,
then you can go to a new state.
You write a new symbol at
that location on the tape.
And you can move the head
either left or right.
So that's how we get
the effect of the head
being able to be bi-directional.
And here is the
writing on the tape.
It comes up right here.
So just an example
here which says
that, if we're in state two
and the head is looking at an a
currently on the tape, then
we can move the state r.
We change that a to a b.
And we move the
head right 1 square.
Now, this is important.
When you give a certain input
here to the Turing machine,
it may compute
around for a while,
moving its head back and
forth, as we were showing.
And it may eventually
halt by either
entering the q
accept state or the q
reject state, which I
didn't bring out here,
but that's important.
These are the accepting,
rejecting, special states
of the machine.
Or the machine may never
enter one of those.
It may just go
on, and on, and on
and never halt. We call
that looping, a little bit
of a misnomer, because
looping implies
some sort of a repetition.
For us, looping just
means not halting.
And so therefore, M has
three possible outcomes
for each input, this w.
It might accept w by
entering the accept state.
It could reject w by entering
the reject state, which
means it's going to
reject it by halting.
Or we also say we can
reject by looping.
You can reject the string
by running forever.
That's just the terminology
that's common in the subject.
So you either accept it
by halting and accepting
or rejecting it by either
halting and rejecting
or by just going forever.
That's also considered
to be rejecting,
sort of rejecting in
a sense by default.
If you never actually
have accepted it,
then it's going to be rejected.
OK, check in three here--
all right, so now our
last check in for the day,
we say, this Turing machine
model is deterministic.
I'm just saying that.
But if you look at
the way we set it up,
if you've been following the
formal definition so far,
you would understand
why it's deterministic.
So let's just, as a
way of checking that,
how would we change
this definition?
Because we will look
at the next lecture
at non-deterministic
Turing machines.
So a little bit of
a lead in to that,
how would we change
this definition
to make it a non-deterministic
Turing machine?
Which of those three
options would we use?
So here, I'll launch that poll.
I've got about 10 people left.
Let's give them
another 10 seconds.
OK, I think that's everybody
who has answered it from before.
So here, I think you pretty
much almost all of you
got the right idea.
It is B, in fact, because when
we have the power set symbol
here, that means there
might be several--
there is a subset
of possibilities.
So that indicates several
different ways to go.
And that's the essence
of non-determinism.
OK, so I think we're--
whoops.
All right, so look, this is
also kind of setting us up
for next lecture and where we're
going to be going with this.
So these are basically two
in a-- well, two or three
important definitions here.
One is-- we talked about
the regular languages
from finite automata.
We talked about the
context-free languages
from the grammars and
the pushdown automata.
What are the languages that
the Turing machines can do?
Those are called, in
this course, anyway,
Turing-recognizable
languages, or T recognizable.
Those are the languages that the
Turing machine can recognize.
And so just to make sure we
were on the same page on this,
the language of the machine
is the collection of strings
that the machine accepts.
So the things that are
not in the language
are the things that are
rejected either by looping
or by halting and rejecting.
So only the ones that are
accepted is the language.
Every machine has just
a single language.
It's the language of all strings
that that machine accepts.
And we'll say that and
recognize that language,
if that language is the
collection of such strings
that are accepted.
And we will call that language
a Turing-recognizable language,
if there is some Turing
machine that can recognize it.
Now, this feature of being able
to reject by running forever
is a little bit weird, perhaps.
And from the standpoint
of practicality,
it's more convenient if the
machine always makes a decision
to accept or reject
in finite time
and doesn't just reject
by going forever.
And so we're going to bring
out a special class of Turing
machines that have that
feature, that they always halt.
The halting states,
by the way-- maybe it
didn't say this explicitly--
are the q accept
and the q reject states.
The accept and reject states
are the halting states.
So if the machine
halts, that means
it ends up in one of those two.
So it has made a
decision of accepting
or rejecting at the point
at which it has halted.
So we'll say a machine
is a decider if it always
halts on every input.
So for every w fed
in, the machine
is eventually going to come
to a q accept or a q reject.
We call such a
machine a decider.
And now we're going to
say, a language is--
so we'll say that the machine
decides a language if it's
the language of the machine,
so the collection of accepted
strings, and the
machine is the decider.
We'll say that, instead of
just recognizing the language,
we'll say that it
decides the language.
And the Turing-decidable
language is a language that
the machine--
of all strings the machine
accepts for some Turing machine
which is a decider, which
is a Turing machine that
always halts.
So if a Turing machine may
sometimes reject by looping,
then it's only
recognizing its language.
If the Turing machine
is always halting,
so it's always rejecting
by explicitly coming
to a reject state and
halting, then we'll
say it's actually
deciding the language.
So then, in a sense,
that's better.
And we're going to
distinguish between those two,
because they're not the same.
There are some languages
which can be recognized,
but not decided.
And so in fact, we're going to
get the following picture here,
that the Turing-recognizable
languages are a proper subset.
They include all of--
everything that's
decidable, certainly
is going to be recognizable,
because being a decider
is an additional
restriction to impose,
an additional requirement.
So everything
that's decidable is
going to be automatically
recognizable.
But there are things which
are recognizable which are not
decidable, as we'll see.
I'll actually give
an example of that,
but not prove it next lecture.
And just for, just to
complete out this picture,
I'm going to also point out--
we haven't proven this yet,
but we will prove it--
that the decidable
languages also
include all the
context-free languages,
which, in turn, include
the regular languages,
as was already seen.
So we haven't shown
this inclusion yet.
But actually, this is
the picture that we get.
So there is actually a
hierarchy of containments here.
Regular languages are a subset
of the context-free languages,
which are, in turn, a subset of
the decidable languages, which
in turn, are a subset of the
Turing-recognizable languages.
And so with that,
I think we're going
to move to our little
bit of a review of what
we've done today.
So we proved that
pumping lemma as a tool
for showing that languages are
not context-free languages.
We defined Turing
machines, which
is going to be our model that
we're going to be focusing
on for the rest of the term,
not forgetting the other models,
because they're going to
be useful examples for us.
And we defined Turing deciders,
Turing machine deciders
that halt on all inputs.
OK, so I think, with
that, we have come
to the end of today's lecture.
I will stick around a little
bit and answer questions
in the chat.
I will try to share
them with everybody
as I'm answering them so I'm
not just talking to one person.
How is the concept applied in--
so I'm getting one question
about the practicality
of all this.
Bunches of questions
are coming in.
So look, is this
stuff all practical?
I would say, yes and no.
I don't know which
concept you have in mind.
We're going to introduce lots
of concepts in this course.
And the concept of the finite
automata, and the pushdown
automata, and context-free
languages, definitely
used in other subjects, in
other fields in computer science
and elsewhere-- these are very
basic and fundamental notions.
And so yes, and Turing
machines-- well,
I mean that's a model
of a general computer.
If you want to
understand computation,
you're going to need to
understand some model.
And a Turing machine is a
particularly simple model.
And that's why we use it.
As it turns out,
it doesn't really
matter what model
you use, but we'll
talk about that next time.
But yeah, I would say there
is a lot of applied material
in this course, as time
has shown, whether it's
led to things like public
key cryptography, which
is used on the internet,
or understanding
various algorithms.
I mean, that's not
the reason I study it.
I study it because I'm
more coming at it from more
of a mathematical perspective.
I just find the material very
beautiful, and interesting,
and challenging, but it
does have applications.
Any other questions here?
I think I'm going
to sign off, then,
to get myself set up
for my office hours,
which is on a
different Zoom link.
OK, so thank you, everybody.
And see you on Thursday.
Bye bye.